and the question is for Andrew what are
you working on now that you've retired
from blogging um I guess I'm working on
a book on Christianity for our against
joke just a little joke Patrick would
you ever consider running for public
office again well with four kids seven
and under that won't even be an option
for another 15 years or so why you can't
run with kids in the house
well maybe you can but they won't ever
know who you are so I prefer to get
around how many did Uncle Bobby have
well that's a good point but he had in
double big well you know we learned from
experience right I think it's good thing
to wait around I love politics but I
think I could still run away dandelo on
good relations with all your siblings
and cousins and everybody since the book
I've got a big family some better than
others
ha how's the house Thanksgiving gonna be
this year everybody we might have to
miss that one uh secretary what would
you say to Republican presidential
candidates who say that the first thing
that would do and by the way everything
is always day one yeah
with these [ __ ] everything is day
one is there do they need any other time
in the hole administer a day one they
would rip up the arraign nuclear deal
you know lastly well I'd say the first
thing they should figure out is how
they're gonna deal with all of our
allies who are going to want to leave
the fold and leave us with the worst of
worst of all worlds
we'll have no deal we'll have a big
nuclear program sanctions will probably
erode and then we're stuck it makes no
sense it's such a no-brainer because the
alternative is sanctions but the
sanctions are not an alternative because
the other countries won't go along with
direct I don't know in fact people
forget that the UN sanctions were put in
place specifically to bring Iran to the
table well it's happened and so the idea
that I are going to somehow stick with
us is pretty pretty hard for me but it's
a nothing
who was so against this deal I mean
obviously nobody could have a stronger
interest in keeping a nuke from Iran
he's a smart man he must know this is
the best way to do that as well as in
fact in fact in testimony he gave in
Congress quite a few years ago he
identified exactly that point that the
nuclear weapon was the existential
threat he was talking about Iraq at the
time incorrectly but it's also about
Iran the I think if you actually listen
to a lot of the critiques now of the
agreement it's not about the agreement
it's about what the agreement is not
right and and what Iran is not and
exactly and Obama made the point there
so just about right the one deal it's
not about making Iran perfect right and
so the the the deal is right now that we
have to work with our Gulf allies with
Israel to continue to push back really
hard on all the other things we don't
like about Iran's behavior you know
support for terrorists see what for
anything it has sent me to do it the
fact that in the early 80s Israel did
attack a nuclear facility in Iraq and
did knock it out and maybe they think
well we did it once we could do it again
well today you know I sat at the witness
table between secretary Carter and
chairman of the Joint Chiefs at that
time Marty Dempsey they were asked a
question and they said okay what about
the military option and the answer was
yeah we could set the program back two
or three years so that's great
set the program back two or three years
have it grow back with greater hardening
against future attacks have the program
build up have no verification versus 15
years of rolling the program back
verification forever it's kind of like
how do I choose between these two
options and international since for the
obvious and and international support
exactly and by the way so it's just it's
you know the fact is from where we are
nobody has put put forward a credible
plan B and this gets us 15 years of
rollback of the program plus
verification and international support
the verification certainly forever
international support for
long time it would have been good though
if we've been able to keep those
sanctions on because the reason they
came to the table is that they knew that
they were cratering edge we have kept
the sanction zone first of all they're
on there's a lot of confusion the only
sanctions relieved are those
specifically on nuclear not sanctions on
support of terrorism and other issues
number one right number two the UN
sanctions on weapons and on missiles was
pointed out by some of our partners
we're supposed to go away when they came
to the table we have extended those for
five years in eight years respectively
not to mention that they remain lots of
other sanctions in place on things like
but like missiles that the financial
relief we gave them as part of the
unfreezing of their assets basically
gave them an ATM machine to fuel
terrorism throughout the Middle Way well
given that to them I mean they we only
give it well if they honor the deal and
if they get rid of their nuclear program
then we basically unfreeze what was
their money in fact if I may add on fact
on this program some time ago one of
your guests talked about 150 billion
dollars being freed up well first of all
that's a fiction already it's it's it's
a lot of money but it's closer to 50
then 150
secondly the they have it is it's hard
to argue that the actions that we very
much dislike are today resource limited
you know all there's all kinds of
so-called asymmetric activities right so
furthermore they have got a half a
trillion dollar hole to dig out of now
we never say that none of these funds
will go to support the Revolutionary
Guard and some some some additional
military support but we also firmly
believe that almost all of this is going
to go I mean to start digging out of a
hole to me people in politics especially
conservatives used to understand the
concept of well the best of all it
we don't live in the best of all
possible worlds we could just take the
best of things that are also bad mm-hmm
that they're ours no great answer
there's only the least shitty answer hmm
that's real politic that's that's meta
Nick that's Henry Kissinger and other
ancient Germans it's Bismarck that's
what they understood right the art of
compromise allows the worst folk option
is what you do and it's also if I may
say it's also if you go back to Ronald
Reagan he had a lot of pressure to
negotiate the master bargain labor
issues of Jewish immigration there were
issues of proxy wars but he chose to
negotiate an arms control agreement and
accomplish something and that in fact
then led to lots of other things down
the road there's a certain analogy at
least it's also great to get this sort
of off the table it was the one issue or
it's the opposition in Iran the people
who were gunned down in the streets
agreed with the regime ah it was the
nuclear program what having the right to
enrich was something that United all of
them and the people that really didn't
want this to happen with the
Revolutionary Guards and if we had a
wedge issue it was a wedge openly did
something smart and not only that even
though I you know I think one has to be
very you know very doubtful and
certainly not optimistic but one can
hope that we've given some sort of
opening for the people in Iran who read
Iran should really be our ally Iran is
our natural ally could reach absolutely
and and they are amazing people it's one
of the it's one of the great
civilizations in mankind they love this
country so many of them so many of them
are young and I saw that in the Green
Revolution and I just felt yeah you're
right absolutely right bill about the
least worse but there's also something
quite hopeful here yes there could be
first time a glimmer of some kind of the
only country that really could help the
middle east of questions whether we
support that and rose like whether we
actually do what we did you know as we
did before and support democracy there
that'll be a big I don't want they want
all right but I think they can do it on
their own so Ann Marie are you are women
get
closer to having it all so you know men
don't have it all either men definitely
don't have it all either but I don't
like to I don't like the frame I'm not
talking about having it all I'm talking
about equality which is a much better
way of thinking about it and yeah we're
getting closer to equality but we've got
a way to go I have to say Patrick
listening to you and hearing you say you
know you're not going to run for
Congress because you actually want to
see your kids and be with them while
they're young that's moving closer to a
quality so I think we're getting better
but if every I mean certainly having
children cannot preclude people from
being in Congress we're all stood be
very few people in Congress well that's
okay look why can't you you know be have
a job and also have children you can if
you have somebody else at home willing
to take care of them but what he's
saying is he wants to be there too he's
not going to rely on his wife to take
care of them and my point is that's
great if more people said you know why
you have kids you're going to focus on
your kids you're going to work - of
course you're going to work but you know
that's a perfectly legitimate reason to
say I'm gonna defer a big job until my
kids are grown sector deficit no just to
say you want to spend time with the
people that you love and watch them grow
up because those moments are gonna go by
and you're not gonna get them back but
most people obviously don't have the
resources but to parents the stay home
that's the babies question okay ah
they're both working that's not the
point the point is hello
Rob Thomas do you support artists who
boycott Digital streaming services like
Spotify uh I don't see I don't see any
use in it do you know I mean I think at
some point you're gonna be on one side
of what's gonna happen like the the
state of the music industry especially
the you know the kind of antiquated idea
of it it's really [ __ ] but the state of
music is really fascinating right now
the ability to have the thing to have
the the closeness and to be able have
access to your favorite artists into
music and all kinds of media like
there's a while ago when you have three
different ways that you hate music
well I don't get this this yeah I think
you do pay for and I think that you know
there's there's artists out there now
there's artists out there now that are
getting money through publishing getting
fans to come see them play that Witten
through the three traditional ways that
used to get music if they didn't play
you on that radio station or didn't see
you on vh1 or see you on MTV they're
really talented artists that never could
have a career and now that there's a way
for fans of music to go find them on
their own to go right from their house
they're not making any money on Spotify
no automatic Joe it's funny really
record labels are making money from
Spotify and I think you know I'm sure
that I get a good one eighth of a cent
off every time they play my song that
you you don't get you don't get anywhere
near that from Spotify you don't get
anywhere near that's an eighth of a cent
that's also happening in you know if
you're a writer in this country at this
point in time I mean the industry that I
grew up into it just doesn't exist right
and the the number of young people who
can actually own a living writing or
reporting is vanishingly small and and
and the all the pressure downward is is
continuing on writers ability to simply
live and pay that bill and after 20
years like I I was lucky enough I think
to come in where I built a fan base like
for me I'm everything I do is you got
anymore I went to a good time I want
people to come see me play live I want
people to come like follow me with the
home game I don't care if they're buying
my music I don't care if they're
stealing my mood that's easy for you to
say because you came up at a time when
we didn't ask anybody the question right
well I mean you know you got to think
about the younger generation I mean
night I under I understand and I think
that right now it's a lot harder for
somebody even you know when those fans
can find them it's a lot
of them to really turn that into a into
a business all right I got one last
question it's not from here it's from me
it is playoff time probably as we speak
right now the Mets are kicking ass
against the Dodgers hopefully I'm sure
they are but there was another baseball
story I wanted to ask you this CC
Sabathia you're familiar he's a Yankee
pitcher and on the eve of the playoffs
you know the Yankees were limited but
this happened before they were
eliminated CC Sabathia said I got to go
to rehab and I thought and everybody
said oh hero
what a great thing I great I'm so proud
of him
and I thought really kind of selfish you
couldn't wait a month playoff time and
his teammates were like you know I
didn't even know he had a problem I mean
huh it's it's it's a good laugh because
that's what we do to understand this but
the fact is I mean this could have been
life or death we don't know because we
weren't in his shoes and the bottom line
is very one bad guy one more month well
tell that to his kids yeah let me know I
deal with the night before yeah you
don't know what what was going on in his
family what what if there was a vote for
Obamacare and you were in the Congress
and you were the deciding vote and it
was happening the next day and you'd
have to stay in Congress another few
weeks would you go nope
I'm out got to go take care of my rehab
thing it's not a rehab Lloyd came I'll
say are we are we waiting a baseball
game to that come on get
I'm just saying
hey if I were a Yankees fan and thank
God I'm not I'm a Red Sox fan do it what
see where they might be ill no way I can
see better but you know everybody knows
life is more important than a game okay
thank you very much everybody thank you
audience OH
you